dan waiki he covers the lakers and the
nba for the la times kind enough to join
us all right give me the initial
basketball reaction when you heard
patrick beverly was joining the lakers
i think it was
oh okay
dan i wasn't stunned right when patrick
beverly
got traded to utah
i think the
the feeling around the league was that
he would land somewhere else and
certainly he gives the lakers a lot of
what they need
or want right defensive tenacity
he's a really good spot up shooter i
think if you told me today that patrick
beverly was going to play 82 games in a
lot of ways he's a real like almost a
perfect lebron james teammate doesn't
really need the ball on offense
um defends his butt off and is you know
has been in his career a pretty
underrated three-point shooter right
like 34 last year that's the worst he's
ever been in the nba
um so i i think like that's all really
good news um i think the durability
stuff is real though um that's gotta be
a concern for a team that already has
injury concerns and then i think
dan secondarily and i have a feeling you
wonder this too is like okay are there
more shoes to drop yeah
yeah
okay so
do you think that this is a move that
will lead to another move dan
i i i don't know and i wish i had a
clearer picture i think that the lakers
have been trying to trade russell
westbrook um that's not a surprise
um they were
certainly interested in kyrie irving and
i think and i wrote this that you know
when that when when that kind of
situation in brooklyn got settled
earlier this week it kind of provided a
clarity for the lakers and so like okay
we can go about now doing our business
like we don't have to wait on this
situation to play out anymore
we can kind of put our foot in the
ground and pivot
and you know go about making our team
better because it needed to get better
right and
um while taylor horton tucker is a a
young player he he wasn't going to make
the lakers that much better this year i
really don't believe um that his skills
fit with what they have already so you
know this is a step in that direction
um but you know russell westbrook's
still really hard to trade dan um it's a
lot of money there's not a lot of
interest around the league um you know i
i spoke to a general manager here in the
last 24 hours and i kind of mentioned
russell westbrook and trading him and
that generator just said good luck
you know um and i don't think that
opinion has changed much since the trade
deadline last year
and i'll be curious i am very curious to
see if the lakers can kind of how
aggressive they will be
um in terms of adding draft capital you
know two first-round picks perhaps to
making a russell westbrook move to kind
of try to bolster the roster again here
for
you know this isn't lebron's last chance
i don't think but you know we're in that
territory
i see bring in patrick beverly
the role that he play how does that
impact russell westbrook
yeah it's going to make for a fun
employee orientation
i think then i think right like like the
icebreaker games like you know are going
to be really really awkward around that
table um if they're both there
uh you know in some ways it should be
good news for russell westbrook darvin
hamm has talked a lot about you know
we want we want russell to kind of be in
the corner and hit threes and and to be
a defender and we're going to challenge
him to be a defender and that's not
really
who russell westbrook has ever been in
the nba it is who patrick beverly has
been and you know there is maybe a
a logic to you know this opens up you
know russ is not going to be more
miscast he'll be able to do kind of the
things he's more comfortable with but i
mean we saw that how that played out
last year right and that was a struggle
so
i don't know i i don't think this makes
russell westbrook a more seamless fit
with the lakers um but i do think that
generally speaking right like patrick
beverly is a guy that 29 teams generally
you know mostly hate and when he's on
your team like you love the stuff that
he does because he does the type of
things that you know make a basketball
team more more compelling and and you
know a toughness and a care factor
that are really easy to get behind and
you know this is a guy who cares about
winning and he plays with a ton of
intensity and heart
and i don't think that's ever a bad
thing
frank vogel was supposed to be or
labeled a defensive minded head coach
you bring in darvin ham who's going to
be asking his team to do the same play
defense why is darvin ham
an upgrade or
considered an upgrade or a move that was
necessitated by how they played over
frank
yeah so i i think you know it's just i
think it's different right dan and i
think sometimes different is the upgrade
you know um right frank vogel you know
through a year and a half with the
lakers really through the first two
seasons you know architected the best
defense in the nba you know won the
title in his first year um that was a
defensive minded team um was in a great
position defensively in year two kind of
coming off that bubble championship
before
injuries kind of took their toll and
then last year was you know just a
disaster on a ton of fronts and frank
fogle had a hand in that the front
office had a pen and that the players
had a hand in that it really was sort of
a
uh you could kind of you know blindfold
yourself throw a dart and you hit
somebody with some blame
um i think where darvin ham is different
right is that darwin ham
is um the lakers have used the word
presence people have used the word
presence running what i think that means
is he's he's maybe a little more
confrontational
um you know definitely a different
approach to dealing with people less
dispassionate um that's not to say frank
local doesn't care he absolutely cares
music massive competitor and a really
good basketball coach i i just think
that like you know like that sort of
approach the kind of you know he could
he got kind of labeled like ted lassoey
around the team you know a good dad joke
here or there and stuff like that i
think you know maybe
mak maybe somebody would grab you by
your jersey
and you know hit you with an f-bomb now
or then i think was is maybe like that's
the change and now we'll see if that's
better or worse you know if that fixes
the problem i still haven't talked to
anybody who thinks that the lakers only
problem was coaching you know like
that's it's not a one-step
fix um but it is different and i think
it'll hit some guys differently i'll
leave you with this this our poll
question today
i'm excited which trio plays more games
this upcoming season a.d lebron and russ
kd kyrie ben simmons
oh my god
um
i i think the latter i think brooklyn
just because i still think that
there is a chance the lakers will be
able to put together a russell westbrook
trade um you know depending on their
willingness
it seems like brooklyn is moving
forwards in that path and you think
kyrie stays with brooklyn
it seems like it dan it really does
right now um it seems like it we'll see
you know they weren't brooklyn wasn't
able to extract a ton of value
from from around the league like kind of
in the brief sort of period when he was
trade eligible
um we'll see if that changes close to
the trade deadline we'll see i think i
think there's certainly a possibility
um but basketball wise i kind of think
that like ben simmons and kyrie irving
are actually a pretty good fit
um you know and if everybody's bought in
and healthy like
it could work there's just a lot of
chaos there certainly but i think they
make sense um certainly more sense in
the lakers trio and and so that to me
that they'll get my vote
dan thanks for joining us we appreciate
it
all right thanks for having me talk to
you soon dan
he covers the lakers nba for the la
times